so Perry and I have been running the
executive programs at the d.school at
Stanford for the last several years and
we've had the great pleasure of hosting
hundreds and thousands of professionals
just like you at Stanford getting them
immersed in the tools of design thinking
but we weren't satisfied just with
hosting professionals here our goal with
innovation at work is to take the same
tools that we teach here at Stanford and
bring them into your context into your
office and put them to work on
challenges that matter to you so how
it's going to work is each portion of
innovation at work has two sections one
is about actually practicing a skill and
the other one is doing it at work the
way it's gonna work is we will give
instructional video and interjections
even throughout that that'll run
concurrent with your work so you'll be
working in sometimes right beside us
sometimes will prompt you to do work and
you'll dive right into it whatever it is
though I assure you it's gonna be active
in the room you're gonna be up you're
gonna be moving and you're gonna be
using these tools real-time this
innovation at work course is different
from any other online course you've
taken for two reasons one it's actually
project-based meaning that we'll give
some instruction and then you're working
on a real project the second thing is
rather than sitting with your own
computer at your desk doing the class by
yourself you'll be with a group of your
colleagues working on developing these
tools and applying them to your
challenge together so people who
generally come to innovation to work
leave their laptops at their desk and
come with an attitude ready to engage
and collaborate and an openness to try
on new tools of innovation to bring back
to their team and their work so these
innovation at work sessions will each be
about 90 minutes the first one will
always be practice will actually go
through a skill and actually sort of
tool you up and actually use a challenge
that we have to teach you the the tools
we want you to learn the second one will
always be about a problem that you have
in your work and will apply those tools
to that challenge in the sessions we'll
give instruction and video sometimes
demonstrating will give a certain amount
of time to get it done but know that if
you need to hit play or pause during the
session
that's pretty cool you can do that and
you can actually continue on with the
session as if we were there the whole
time right the goal though is for you to
take these tools seriously and for you
to feel confident and capable of
applying them to work that matters to
you oh yeah and one more thing I forgot
to tell you the sessions are active
you won't need a computer at all that's
great